[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Hello everyone.
We are now going to start
our fourth and final panel.
And to do that, I'm going to
do so our moderator, Adrienne
Keene.
Adrienne is an assistant
professor of American Studies
at Brown University.
She was previously a
Presidential Diversity
Post-doctoral Fellow
there affiliated
with the Department
of Anthropology
and the Center for the Study of
Race and Ethnicity in America.
Her work focuses
on the experiences
of American Indian,
Alaskan Native
and Native Hawaiian students
in the college process.
She is also the
author and editor
of Native Appropriations, a
very well-known blog exploring
representations of indigenous
peoples in popular culture.
Adrienne.
[CLAPPING]
-[SPEAKING CHEROKEE]
Hi, everyone I'm Adrienne Keene.
I'm a citizen of
the Cherokee Nation.
And I am also an alumni
of the Harvard Graduate
School of Education.
So I can't tell you how happy I
am that this event is happening
on our campus, and to
see all of you here,
and to have these conversations
be a part of this community
is amazing.
So thank you, so much,
to HUNAP and Radcliffe,
and all of the organizers
who made this possible.
It really means a lot to
me as an alum to be here.
So in my work, I often start
with a basic phrase which
is representations matter.
And we've heard, and seen,
today how vitally important
it is to have native peoples
and native voices in realms
from law to governance to
literature and art and, now,
media.
We live in a world
where the average person
spends 490 minutes a
day consuming media.
That is over eight hours,
over half of our waking day,
and that's set to rise to
506 minutes by next year.
And we know the type of
images that the public
is receiving of native peoples.
I had a whole paragraph
going into it,
but I think Matika did a
wonderful job talking about it.
And these stereotypes
still dominate.
These images, also, often
place native peoples
in the historic past,
and we were never
pictured as contemporary
human beings,
but always as something that
exists in stark contrast
to modernity.
The process of placing us in the
historic past, and therefore,
extinct, or as fantasy creatures
on the same level as mermaids
and wizards, obscures our
ongoing strengths, triumphs,
and advances, but
it also obscures
the real and pressing challenges
in our communities, as well.
If native people
are only situated
in the imaginations
of the public,
we will never have the
support and understanding
we need to move our
communities forward.
The other side of
misrepresentation,
for native peoples,
is invisibility.
Because representations is
not just about stereotypes,
it's also about the
lack of representations,
or the all encompassing
invisibility native peoples
experience in society.
As an example, in an analysis
of prime time television shows
between 1989-2009, researchers
found that native characters
ranged between 0%-0.6%
of the overall numbers.
So in raw numbers, that
translates to only three
native characters.
So three native characters in 20
years of prime time television
data.
And this invisibility
has real effects
on how native
peoples understand,
in the words of
Stephanie Fryberg,
and her colleague
Stephens, who they are
and what they see as
possible for themselves.
Without counter narratives,
or positive representations,
of native peoples to
draw upon, our ability
to imagine ourselves in
the future is limited.
In this environment
of invisibility,
every representation takes
on increased importance.
On this panel, we have those who
have fought hard both within,
and outside of, the
film and media industry
to make change for native
peoples in these arenas,
and to imagine what the future
of native film and media
can look like.
While so much of
the conversation
is often about critique,
and while I believe
this is necessary
and very important--
as it is what I do
every day on my blog--
I am excited to be able to
share the stage with three
native advocates who've
been making space
for media by, and
for, native peoples,
creating positive
counter narratives
and disrupting stereotypes.
What does it look like when
native peoples are given
the power and control
to represent themselves
in media and film?
So on this panel we have Irene
Bedard, Migizi Pensoneau,
and Loris Taylor.
And I direct you to the
program to read their bios that
demonstrate the depth and
breadth of knowledge we
have on this stage.
I'm really excited to
learn with you today.
And without further
ado, I will turn it over
to our first panelist, so
[SPEAKING CHEROKEE]
Thank you.
[CLAPPING]
-[NON-ENGLISH] Thank you.
Thank you to the people
of this land, Wampanoag.
Thank you, honorable colleagues,
honorable human beings,
distinguished mothers and
fathers, daughters and sons,
but especially our ancestors
and the coming generations.
I am humbled and honored
to be in your presence
at this critical juncture in
the arc of human existence.
I'm Inupiaq, Yupik,
and Metis Cree.
My name Irene means peace.
My Yupik name Kautaurak
means one who dropped.
[PTSEEW]
And my Cree name is Iron Woman
to the Core of the Earth.
I was born and raised in Alaska.
And I'm the daughter of
Bruce and Carol Bedard
and the granddaughter of
David and Irene [? Oten ?]
from the village
of Kodiak, which
thrives from the gifts
of the Bering Sea.
Yes.
I am indigenous.
But I am a citizen of the world,
a tiny human being on the face
the planet called Mother Earth.
On this day before
you, I could speak
of the villages
that have been moved
inland due to the melting
of the Arctic Ocean,
and the many more that the
Army Corps of Engineers
plan to move in the near future.
I could speak of the polar
bears or the cancer clusters
attributed to the burning
of random found materials
used to keep homes, in the long
winter, in the villages warm.
But instead, as in the
tradition of my people,
I am going to tell you a story.
The story of us.
I will begin with my
ancestor, my mother.
She was born in the
village of Kodiak, Alaska
in 1948, Cold War America.
The United States government
was conducting tests
on the effects of nuclear
radiation on human beings,
using the villagers of Point
Hope as their test subjects.
But not so far away, in the
scheme of human history,
my mother was born and in her
lifetime lived 10,000 years.
She lived the way we always
lived, subsistence hunting,
fishing, and gathering.
When she was still
a girl, an airplane
came, and took her to
the boarding school.
From there she went to
the big city of Anchorage.
And rode in a car,
though she never drove.
On television, she saw
a man land on the moon.
Then came computers
and cell phones
and the world wide web
was cast around the world.
She got to hear Elvis
sing on the radio,
and then see him in a movie.
You see, we human beings
have the same story.
We all came from tribes.
We all hail from the
Earth with songs,
and stories, drums, and
dances, and the deep abiding
relationship to our ancestors,
the coming generations,
and our Mother Earth.
Our mother taught
us well how to live
and from generation
to generation,
we pass the ancient
knowledge of our ecosystem,
the plants, the animals, the
creatures of the sky and sea.
We were one with
our environment.
And she was our
blessed relation.
But we human beings wanted
a sense of autonomy,
like any young person
leaving the nest.
Our intelligence, an integral
tool of our survival,
became our wings.
And we began our journey of
our eco-alienation, farming
and agriculture made way to
the Industrial Revolution.
And only within
the last century,
science became
our final answers.
We cover our earth
with our compounds,
paving our way to the future.
Separated lords over
our long history
as children of an ecosystem.
But now, on this
auspicious occasion,
by the wisdom of humanity,
that science, our intelligence,
is finding its way back.
It is imperative to the survival
of the coming generations
that we find ways to honor
and protect our relations,
and bring us back to
balance with Mother Earth.
That was my speech
that I had prepared
for the United Nations.
You see how a story
brings us all together.
Healing through the
power of storytelling
is what we do in
filmmaking and television.
I only think of myself
as a storyteller.
Yes, I'm just a
girl from Alaska,
but I think I might be the
storyteller of my tribe.
We have this report here
that I wanted to just show
you, Inclusion or invisibility?
Comprehensive Annenberg Report
on Diversity in Entertainment.
Let me just kind of push
through it really fast here.
Gender, here we are speaking
of gender, and media platforms.
Behind the camera
gender, as well.
We move forward.
And here we have
race and ethnicity.
You see the
prevalence onscreen--
and thank you for bringing
up those numbers there.
If you can see here,
forward, as we go forward,
we have the film, broadcast
cable, streaming, and number
of shows without any black
or Asian speaking characters
by media platform.
Betrayal on screen white,
Latino, black, Asian, other.
Other that what we get.
When I was growing up, I
wanted to be invisible.
I was one of very few
native girls, native people,
in the high school
that I went to.
And it was so much
easier to be invisible.
It was so much safer
to be invisible.
I read that book The Invisible
Man, and I understood.
I felt a kinship to that.
But we are the invisible people.
Zero representation throughout
the last number of years,
throughout most of those years.
Today, let's see, I'm on
a television series called
Longmire, which was on A&E
and got moved to a streaming
network called Netflix.
But it's the story of
a really great guy who
happens to be a cowboy Sheriff.
We still continue to have these
conversations of invisibility,
these conversations
of our nature,
of where we belong in the fabric
of-- not just American society,
but the society
throughout this world.
It's been a difficult
place to come from.
But if you see, in this
picture, this is me.
That parka was given
to be my grandmother.
The fox was caught
by my grandfather.
That ring was
100-year-old Navajo ring.
And I found out the turquoise in
it came all the way from Nepal.
And it was given
to me by my father.
We come to this place.
Who controls the narrative?
We go from building
bridges to the other
because that's what we're going
to have to do in this media
environment that we're in.
I was on a plane, while I was
filming a series called Into
the West, which at
that time was a really
big deal in American Indian
country, especially those of us
in front of the camera.
There were 500 speaking
roles, and many of those roles
were Native American people.
This was an incredible story
that Steven Spielberg put
forth, and incredibly
enough, he had
to do the same thing
that the directors
and producers of the film
Roots did 30 years before.
He had to go in
and tell the story
of a romance
between Lakota woman
and a Virginian
wheeler and their trek
across-- during
westward expansion.
That was how that story
needed to be pitched.
It couldn't be pitched as a
story about the deconstruction
of the American
Indian people, which
is what it was really about.
The reason I have this
picture up here right now.
We all belong to the same bird.
It's important for us, all
of us, in this society,
to recognize that we are all
here, part of the same bird.
We're all flying around the
universe on the same planet.
And if we do not understand that
we are woven into the same rug,
and allow each
thread to be who they
are, to weave this
beautiful rug,
then we are never going to
be whole under our feet.
We are never going
to be able to fly,
because we're not allowed
to be part of the same bird.
And I was on this
plane, the Laker's jet,
between Los Angeles
and New York when
we were going to the big
junkets for Into the West.
And I'm sitting there
with the executives.
And I'm talking to them
about some of the projects
that I've thought of,
or that should be made,
or that could be made.
And he looked at me, and he
just basically, said, well,
promoting in the middle of
promoting this major television
event, DreamWorks on
TNT, said, well you're
just not a demographic.
There are 400 million
indigenous people
on this planet, let
alone the native people
of this continent.
Let alone people who have
an interest in who we are,
and what we're about, and
the stories we have to tell,
and what kinds of things we
have to offer to the planet,
including our ancient
technologies, including
the eyes and the ears and
voices of our grandmothers
and our grandfathers.
Including the next generation,
and the next generation,
and the next
generation, things they
should dream and see about
themselves on screen,
and know that they are part of
the fabric of the story telling
of us, all of us human beings.
That's my mom and
her twin sister.
Just had to put that in there.
[LAUGHTER]
My very first film
was a film called
Squanto a Warrior's Tale.
Squanto, you may
remember, was there
at the first Thanksgiving.
He was actually one of my
heroes before that because he
was someone I knew from the
history books that represented
who I am, or at least something
about what I understood
in this world, the
people I came from,
and that I was
represented in history.
Woo hoo!
That was so cool, right?
And that we got this kind
of celebration once a year.
Well I call these characters
the Manifest Destiny characters.
I have, I feel very privileged,
to have had the chance to do
a lot of those characters.
Squanto, in my understanding
of his story growing up,
I was maybe told it a
little bit deeper than some.
And then to be able
to be here on the set
and to be able to tell this
story about this person who
was plucked, kidnapped, sent
across this great big ocean,
plucked, dropped in the
middle of civilization,
shown off like an
animal, a creature.
He escaped and went
to a French monastery.
Was there for decades
hoping to find passage home.
Finally, found passage home.
And when he got there
his entire people
were gone from
warfare and disease.
So he found his way
to another village.
And he could have very easily,
when those pilgrims came,
said Ah, sorry.
You just go ahead and starve.
But he didn't.
He saw that they
were human beings.
And he had empathy
and compassion.
And he did what he
did, yes, and that
is why he ended out
in our history books.
But at the same time,
would you have done that?
Would you have?
To me that is so
telling of the love that
was spoken of earlier, of
the love and the compassion
that we have for one another
as a tribe, as a people.
My grandfather said Bunning,
what does Inupiaq mean?
And I said, I don't know.
He said it just
means human being.
When you go out into the world--
when I left to go to college
and I was going all the way to
the other side of the planet,
as far as I knew-- I dropped in.
It was 90 degrees
and 90% humidity
and I had no idea what that was.
But his words kept me.
You just look people in
the eyes and you will see
that they are a human being.
It's all about the story.
I look you in the eyes and
I want to know your story.
There is a lot of healing in
the power of storytelling.
Later on, actually my
second film that I did
was a film called Lakota
Woman Siege at Wounded Knee.
It was about the siege at
Wounded Knee in 199-- 1993--
1973, we actually
filmed in 1993.
And I had the chance to portray
Mary Crow Dog, Lakota woman.
I had the chance to be
there with the people, many
of the people who
were there in 1973.
I had a chance to
go to Wounded Knee.
I had a chance to see, and
hear, and listen to the voices.
I listened to the voice of Mary.
And I had read the book
before, when I was in college.
I had sent that book to my mom,
and my sister, and my aunties,
because I understood.
I knew this story.
And when I actually met
her, I had heard her voice,
before I had ever even really
actually physically heard her.
That's the connection
that media has.
We connect ourselves
to each other.
In physics, you know,
there's entanglement.
Well, that's what
storytelling is.
It's our entanglement.
And it shows that we are not
so different from each other,
but it also shows that
another point of view.
It gives us a chance
to see through the eyes
and walk through the
feet of someone else.
Someone that we maybe
never got the chance
to meet or understand.
It creates a bridge of
compassion and empathy.
I show this one.
This was a film where I got
to play a tough tribal cop.
Right?
When I open up my little
phone here and I, see inbox.
Oh, I have a meeting, or
a script has been sent,
I know that I'm
going to be looking
at a handful of characters.
Is it going to be the angry,
tough political hates-all
[NON-ENGLISH] woman?
Is it going to be the
disenfranchised, poverty
stricken mother,
you know, victim?
Victim of something,
whether it's rape,
or-- I've been killed
in so many ways.
It's true.
I actually spent one on
two different locations,
on opposite sides of country,
set in two different centuries.
And in that same week,
I spent two whole days
hanging in two different trees.
Let's see, the wise
sage, medicine person
who lacks any sense of
humor or humanity, really.
The alcoholic, drug
addicted crazy.
That's it.
That's what I think of when I'm
about ready to open a script,
which one is it?
I just know if you go out and
with Sleeping Lady Films Waking
Giants Productions, we
have too many stories.
And good news from
Indian country.
Good news from the
indigenous world.
There are so many
positive, amazing stories
of perseverance, and
strength, and dignity.
And even the stories that
are hard and difficult
and should be told because
these are the stories that so
many people just
don't even know,
we tell them with inspiration.
We tell them with a heart of
all human kind, of all mothers,
of all grandmothers, and their
grandmothers before them,
and the child, and the
daughter, and the daughters down
seven generations from me.
That connection that I
have with the projects
that I do, and I've had to
be a part of they're amazing.
I'm so blessed and honored.
I walk in beauty.
I think it's-- I show these
pictures because this goes
back, this is the flapper era,
little bit before the flapper
era.
And doesn't she look native?
She's not.
But that depiction, the
kind of understanding,
of we as native
women and the beauty
that we hold, inherently,
it is a wanted--
there is something about it.
There is something about the
beauty of a native woman.
And about the fact that
we do walk in beauty
to the best of our abilities, in
the hardest and most difficult
circumstances.
We continue to do so.
Even if Barbie would look
like this, if she was really
a human-sized person.
This was something that
very much came up--
and I'm trying to find
where that one is, actually.
I think it's out of
sequence-- with the avatar,
with Pocahontas, which
of course, a lot of you
know that I was the
voice of Pocahontas.
And then I went on and did The
New World by Terrence Malick,
and I played
Pocahontas's mother.
Keep on going on, don't we.
There's that
sexualization, also,
that has happened to Native
American and indigenous women.
And of course, that
includes sexual violence.
John Smith, actually,
no matter where he went,
he had these grand, amazing
adventures, and generally
some beautiful, indigenous,
wild thing did something grand
and amazing in his life.
And with Pocahontas,
though, the one thing
that really struck me
about the story in itself,
was she threw herself
upon John Smith
when she was only 11 years old.
And she stopped a
war from happening.
And so that's why we talk about
the peace of Pocahontas, right?
But I think that inherent story
within itself, whether it's
true or not, that story
that we cling to about it
is the story that-- I
think the reason we cling
to these stories is
that it is something
that we hope and wish for.
We want the happy endings.
We want that sense of dignity.
And you know what?
As far as Disney
princesses go, she
wasn't waiting for her
prince to come and save her.
She saved him.
So moving on.
My time is up.
Winona LaDuke, strong woman.
Two Old Women is
a story that I'm
about to start telling with
Sleeping Lady Films Waking
Giants Productions.
Sleeping Lady Films is
a story about waking
the giant of the indigenous
nature, and heart, and people.
And it's a little bit
of a subversive thing.
I'm really shooting
for peace on earth.
[CLAPPING]
-My name is Migizi Pensoneau.
Or wait-- [NON-ENGLISH]
--not that that's any
of your business, but.
I just realized.
We were laughing
earlier today that I
think that native things
always tend to go long.
And there's that joke about
running on Indian time,
and everything, but
I think it's mostly
because we spend so much
time introducing ourselves.
[CLAPPING]
So you Dene, especially.
Man, all I hear is
like these clicking
noises for like two minutes.
I don't understand,
I'm going to learn.
Just kidding, I know
what you're saying.
I know all your clans.
I've been there.
So by the way, so I get
overwhelmed in like a really
big crowd.
So if you find me just like
staring at you suddenly,
and if I'm like in a
really impassioned part,
I'm not yelling
at you white man.
It's just in the
middle of it, you know.
So I focus to like,
so I'm not like,
oh my god, there's
so many of them.
So I think it's a little
funny that everybody's
like I want to thank
the people that at
you know Wampanoag and
Nipmuc, I'm like yeah, thanks
for your land.
So that's how my mind works.
I go to these really,
really dark places.
But no, thank you,
acknowledge you
and this is-- how many people
from here from Wampanoags
and Nipmuc are here?
Ahoo.
Quite a few, quite a few.
-It's a prairie.
-Oh it's a prairie,
that's right.
How many Dene are here?
[WHOO]
Christ.
They outnumber us all.
So anyway, sorry.
I am Migizi Pensoneau.
And I'm a part of a,
co-founder actually,
of a comedy group
called the 1491s.
We are sketch comedy.
[WHOO]
I know, I know.
I'll take some more,
if you want to give it.
So we do silly videos
and put them online.
And that's really,
seriously, pretty much
the entire breadth of what I do.
I could sit back down
now and you'd be like,
oh I'll just go look those up.
So again 1491s.
And if one of you people
comes up after this
and asks me where we got that
name-- just figure it out.
So we started off
with-- there are
five of us in the group,
myself, Sterlin Harjo's
the filmmaker, Bobby Wilson,
you guys might know him
with the tattoos
on his neck, Dallas
Goldtooth, my little
brother, and Ryan Red Corn,
who we affectionately call
the white guy, because he's
very pale.
But we are all artists
in different rights.
So I'm a screenwriter.
Sterlin Harjo, as I
said, is a filmmaker.
Bobby Wilson is a
fantastic artist.
Ryan Red Corn is a
graphic designer.
And my little brother, Dallas,
is like this powerhouse
of activism in any country.
And so why do we get together
and put these videos online,
like which are really,
really self-deprecating?
I mean if you have
any desire, and you
shouldn't, to see what I
look like under this, you
could find it online.
I'm just saying.
All right.
So but we put up a
video and, again,
I'm sorry I don't have anything
for you-- I mean that would
take up all of my
time-- our videos
generally they range from
2-10 minutes in length.
If I were to show a few, then
it would just eat up everything.
But you can look us up,
1491s, YouTube, Facebook,
all that stuff.
But we put a video up.
And we didn't think
anything of it.
We were, like oh,
yeah, this is just
for friends, family, whatever.
Laugh at us, laugh at ourselves.
But the next week, we're at
tens of thousands of views.
And this is at the
advent of YouTube.
It was just sort of
starting as a platform.
And we're like oh,
there's something here.
And like good Indian men, we
didn't do anything for a couple
years, we sat on it.
But we just let you down.
So we ended up, finally,
after a year or two,
we finally got back together.
And we're like, man,
let's do this again.
And we made a bunch more videos.
And they became just as popular.
And we're like, oh, this isn't
just a fluke, one time thing.
People like seeing us
joke about ourselves.
And let's continue.
And as we continued, we noticed
that the more places that we
got to go and get brought, and
the more places, we performed,
we noticed that
outside of us, there
was this sort of dearth,
this void of native humor.
Which is funny
because you always
hear native people talking
about our humor is our medicine,
our humor is what
keeps us strong.
And I'm like show
it to me in a movie.
I mean outside of like
Smoke Signals or something
like that where, but even
that humor is it sort of a let
me explain this to the general
audience kind of humor as well.
There are humorous bits in it
that are for native people,
and stuff, but a lot of it is
like that scene where they're
going backwards in the car-- the
two women are going backwards
in the car.
That is a scene
that I really liked
and then I really
hated right afterwards.
Because it was like,
oh that's great,
just a quirky little thing.
It's funny they're driving
this car backwards.
It's awesome.
But then it got into
this conversation
about oh, you're going
to need your passports.
And you're like OK.
So let's explain that
natives are an other.
We really seriously don't
need to explain that.
Natives have been
portrayed as an other
for generations and
generations, since the founding.
And so when I saw that
as a young guy, when
Smoke Signals came out,
I was like holy shit
this is entirely like
me to produce thing.
It's huge.
It's amazing.
What's the next
thing going to be?
And there were a lot of things
that were under the radar.
You know Smoke
Signals was so big.
And so the other thing
I started to notice
when we were doing
our 1491s and the more
that we produced-- and we have
over 100 now-- not all of them
are funny.
Some of them are from a
series we call Represent where
we go to different
places and we're like,
here you take the
cameras and we'll
put them on our channel,
that kind of thing.
But the more we did that,
the more that I personally
started to notice that
it's not just like humor,
we're not telling a lot
of different stories here.
So if I were to tell
you-- and it's funny,
because Irene is in
Smoke Signals and so
I did this to her earlier.
I was all hey, I'm going
to describe a movie to you.
Young man, through some
tragic happenstance,
has to go on a
journey, young angry,
native man has to
go on a journey
and come to terms with himself
and his own Indianness,
his identity, what
movie is that?
What movie am I describing?
And so because I
just talked about it,
you could go like oh
that's Smoke Signals.
Oh, wait, no, that's
Powwow Highway.
Oh, wait, no, it's Four
Sheets to the Wind.
Oh, no, it's Drunktown's Finest.
There are different aspects.
And I'm like, where all
of these are coming from?
And part of it is that native
people have not had a chance
to tell their stories yet.
And so I feel like
native people definitely
want to throw in a
lot of explanation.
Like this is where
we come from, this
is what you missed, see
all this that you missed?
But the story-- it gets in
the way of the story moving.
And so I was thinking
to myself like man,
where does that come from?
Why is that so ingrained?
And who are these characters?
As Irene was talking
about, there are a few
that native women can
play, and they're not nice.
My Auntie Casey Camp
is also an actor.
And she want to do a
1491s video one day that
is her doing like an acting
camp for native women
where she's just
like, this is how
you lay next to the tipi
that's on fire, dead.
And she's really
excited about it.
We want to do it someday.
So it's really messed up.
But we're like, OK, where
does that come from?
And so I started thinking
and then I figured it out.
The words were written up
there during Irene's thing,
and it's a loaded thing.
We could talk forever about it.
But it's this idea of
Manifest Destiny right?
God put this thing
here, put this land here
for it to be
conquered, taking over,
for good European
Americans to come in
and cultivate the wilderness,
make something out of it,
make something out of yourself.
And that ideal is one of
the more detrimental things
that happened to native
people, particularly
in terms of imagery.
When you think about
the images that
have come out of just
that one concept, things
like the end of the trail, oh,
I'm on my horse and I'm tired.
I'm defeated.
Or you think about like
the Indian maiden thing,
this native woman that's there
for the white man to conquer.
And you think about that.
And you think about the
idea that native people,
for a long time represented,
the wilderness of America,
the wild, the beast, the savage.
And that is meant to be
tamed, meant to be conquered.
What does that mean for a man?
It means you need to be beaten.
You know American lives on this
idea that natives are dead.
When you fuck with
that idea, it's
problematic for a lot of people.
When you go, no, no, no.
I'm alive.
I got a voice.
I'm going to say some shit.
You're like, [GIBBERISH].
Then, what is America?
Saw a couple of you in here.
I'm like, no, I'm
talking to you.
I'm swearing at you.
My god.
Just trying to duck arrows
and tomahawks and whatnot.
Of words.
Verbal tomahawks is what
I'm launching in your faces.
Yeah, I just said that.
All right.
But no, man.
Like when you mess
with that idea--
and America, when
you think about it,
is founded on a
lot of those ideas.
Asian people are other.
Black people are subservient.
When you mess with
those ideas, man,
people do not like hearing it.
And when you see
how that goes, man.
You know, I saw-- I went
back home to Minnesota
and I saw a sign that said
"police lives matter."
And I'm like, you know what?
There aren't a lot of
black people around here.
Who are you yelling back at?
We're in like
Northern Minnesota.
I'm like, what
are you afraid of?
And then I realized
though, it's the idea
that they're yelling back at.
The idea that somewhere black
lives might matter is like,
what?
No, they don't.
Not as much as mine.
And so like that, along with
like if you tell some people
that native people are alive.
They're here.
They're thriving.
They're growing.
Diana earlier today was talking
about how the population
of Hopis has gone up.
Why?
Outside of that we like
doing what makes that happen.
But it's gone up because we are.
We're living.
We're coming back.
Our languages are coming back.
The things that have
been talked about
are like-- they aren't outside
of the realm of possibility.
What Matika said, people
can learn our languages.
I saw on YouTube, a white
kid speaking Ojibwe.
It blew my mind.
He was a polyglot, and
he was just practicing.
It was amazing.
It's amazing to see.
So when you put a bunch of
like silly men who are like no,
we're just laughing,
joking, having a good time.
We're not defeated.
We're not dead.
We're just like
cracking ourselves up
at our chubby, naked bodies.
And when you do that,
and people go like,
natives are not here, though.
They're dead.
You know, they're gone.
And it really messes
with people's heads.
And it creates this sort of like
needle that just keeps jabbing.
And the more we do
that, the more people
are going to have
to pay attention.
But we have to get
out of it ourselves.
As native filmmakers,
as native people,
we have to embrace not
only the same stories
that have been told.
And we can't just tell
people that we're here.
But we got to reach across.
There's something I call
the audacity of genre
in native cinema.
That means do like
a buddy cop movie.
Do like a teen sex comedy,
like Porky's or American Pie.
For native filmmakers
out there, I tell people.
I'm like, do like
a sci-fi flick.
A horror movie.
Reach across.
Because we don't have to
perpetuate the stereotypes,
but we can embrace
archetypes of other stories.
And that's fine.
And people can relate.
Other people will actually
see what you're doing.
They will see what
your places look like.
They'll see your homes.
And it will be on your terms.
So that's why I do what I do.
I found out recently that the
documentarian, Billy Luther,
who I have a lot of respect
for, did Miss Navajo.
The documentary Miss Navajo.
And I found out he did a
movie called Red Lake, which
one of the things
that I said when
I was jibbering at you in Ojibwe
was-- ojibberish as we say.
One of the things
that I was saying
is that I'm from Red
Lake. [SPEAKING OJIBWE].
That means I'm from Red Lake.
And so like when I saw that
he was doing documentary,
I was like, hell yeah, man.
A native dude's
doing a documentary
about where I'm from.
That's awesome.
Because you know, Red Lake
has this complex issue
of sovereignty.
There are certain treaties
that we didn't sign
and it gives us a
lot of autonomy.
And I was like,
oh, that's great.
What's it going to be about?
And I look it up and Red Lake
is about a school shooting,
and about how our people
are sad but still proud.
And I was like, well, fuck.
So that is the kind
of thing-- that's
the reason that we do
what we do, to change
that narrative completely.
Because you know, I ain't
trying to burn down America.
But I mean, I might be trying
to make it great again.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
-Oh my goodness.
So I don't have any talent
like Irene and Migizi.
True story.
I took acting classes
in Los Angeles,
and the director kept saying,
you know, on Wednesday night
we have script writing.
So needless to say,
I'm going to talk
about infrastructure today,
just bring you back to reality.
I need the little
remote thing here.
So I want to first start
off by a quick introduction.
I come from the
village of Oraibi,
that Diane Judge Humetewa
mentioned this morning.
It's a village that has no
running water, no telephone
service.
And when I was younger,
we didn't even have radio.
No television.
Of course, I mentioned that.
And no broadband.
And so years later, I've
now become an advocate
for the digital and media
divide in this country
that is so wide.
And someone once said to
me, they said, dang, Loris.
You're really over-qualified.
You're like the poster child.
So I want to take
you on this journey
and just remind you why media
matters in this country.
Media access,
control, and ownership
is really, quite frankly,
about power and position.
Seeking power and
position over others
is embedded in human cultures.
We build institutions and
systems of administration
and we predicate
this on formulas
that have evolved from
cultural imbalances, which
includes hierarchy,
imperialism, and so forth.
Whoever is in power
gets to tell their story
through their optics and lens.
And they often do this to
justify their own power
and existence.
So I love this map.
Media access,
control, and ownership
is also about ownership capital.
There's a perpetual pursuit
of capital or the ownership
and competitive
acquisition of resources.
We do this through titles, how
we acquire spaces and places.
And this includes our
airwaves spectrum, including
radio and television
frequencies are no exception.
It pretty much is
like land and water,
except that we got into
the fight much later.
In most major markets, like
Phoenix or Minneapolis,
and in the commercial
broadcast environment,
radio and television
ownership is
held by major commercial
conglomerates.
Consolidated media ownership is
a huge problem in this country.
Native Public Media did a small
market study of Albuquerque
about, I would
say, six years ago.
And out of 52 stations
that existed in that town,
only 1 station dedicated any
hours of native programming
to the communities that
surrounded them-- KUNM.
Look it up.
Very sad when New Mexico
has quite a large number
of Native American tribes
within its boundaries.
Media access,
control, and ownership
is really important to
overcoming intolerance,
stereotypes that everyone
has mentioned today.
And really, just
patronizing Native Americans
in this country, which
is still going on today.
Without media access,
control, and ownership,
we cannot fully acknowledge
the injustices of the past
on our own terms.
And so this is really
what drives my work.
By having our own
broadcast facilities,
we begin to actively value
the rich cultural diversity
among tribes in the
context and structures
of our most exalted
institutions economically,
socially, culturally,
and educationally.
A few years back,
Native Public Media
served as an advisor to a
major public service media
institution in the
Boston area, WGBH.
You may have heard of them.
We helped to produce
four major films.
And for the life of me, I
can only remember three.
They included Wounded Knee,
Geronimo, and The Mayflower.
Now, I had to include
this because there's
a continuing romantic notion
about Native Americans.
It's sort of that
Fabio effect that
continues to be present today.
Media access, control,
and ownership,
it's about parity
and justice as well.
In modern America, the
revolution is not over.
And in fact, it's just
beginning for Indian country.
It strikes this closed-offness.
Or, I would say, the
censorship of voices
that ought to be heard,
really strikes to the heart
of the First Amendment.
It strikes to the heart
of our freedom to speak,
the freedom of the press,
and the freedom to be heard.
And let me just
give you an example.
A few years back,
not too long ago,
the Arizona State legislature
passed Arizona House Bill 2281,
which was really to silence
and censor the ethnic voices
within the state of Arizona.
And what it does is that
it prohibits ethnic studies
in schools that are funded by
the state and makes it illegal,
in fact.
This is quite disturbing
because Arizona is home
to 22 tribal nations.
One of the states that has
the largest native populations
in this country.
When we have the power to
access, control, and own
our own media facility,
we are actively
working towards the full
recognition of the impact
of our own history.
We are able to assess our role
and place in the hierarchy
of power and control.
And we can optimize our
personal and professional energy
to tell our own stories.
And also, look out for our
own wellness and happiness.
Media access,
control, and ownership
is about being our own
stewards and guardians
of our own freedom.
Now, Sherman Alexie is a
record holder of banned books.
He held it in 2014.
And if you look it up today,
he's holding it in 2016.
And the reasons for banning
his books range from the fact
that he's like writing
about insidious stuff
that could harm
society, like murder
and violence and rude language.
And so I thought about that.
I used to teach at a
little-known school
just a short distance from
here, Phillips Exeter Academy.
You may have heard of it.
And I remember that
one of our textbooks
was quite Shakespearean
in nature.
And I was thinking, like, wow.
All these elements.
I think I remember
those stories.
And I was thinking,
like Romeo and Juliet.
So there's really no rhyme
or reason to the reasons
why he continues to
be on a banned book.
But it does drive me to go out
and buy copies of his books
for all my friends.
Media access,
control, and ownership
is understanding and
exercising our own power.
Media is based on an unshakable
consciousness of superiority,
imperial conquest
and colonization,
and it's directly linked to
information, social structures,
media messages, and
educational curriculum.
When I started my
work back in 2004,
I read about all
the 10 commissioned
studies by the Federal
Communications Commission.
And what I learned was that the
commission saw Native Americans
through the optics of that
we were vulnerable, unserved,
under-served, and probably
the most fragile and invisible
in the United States.
So I wanted to do
something about that
because media access,
control, and ownership
is really about
the power to speak
and the power to be heard.
It's about our affirmation
of our identity.
It's about cultural survival.
It's about native language
programming, cultural content,
history, and localism.
And it's an exercise of
our tribal sovereignty
and self-determination.
One of the things that we
do from Native Public Media
is to host a one-week
high school boot
camp in communications
for young people.
And we immerse them in
television and radio
and different platforms
on the internet.
And what we want to do is build
capacity across Indian country.
Native Public Media since
2004 has helped tribes
to bring broadcast
facilities to Indian country.
And our work is just beginning.
We're not done.
In our network, we
have 58 radio stations,
3 terrestrial
television stations.
We do everything from high-power
to low-power broadcast
facilities, AM/FM, public
service media, commercial,
and now digital.
Because if we want to
stand on our own two feet,
we need to work against
being silenced by rules
and regulations and laws.
We need to make sure that there
is engagement, consultation,
and that we overcome
invisibility
and the "other" box.
Freedom is part of
the process in terms
of media access and ownership.
It's a validation
of who you are.
We can write our own history.
And the modern pen
are the channels
that we exercise
control over, which
includes broadcast facilities.
And one of the
fundamental questions
we have to ask ourselves
is, whose democracy is it?
To overcome and to in part
answer this question, in 2010
we worked for a tribal
priority for broadcasting.
Not because we were
minorities in this country,
but because we come from
sovereign governments,
and that flows into
our individualism
as tribal members.
We also established in 2010,
the FCC Office of Native Affairs
and Policy.
And when we first
floated the idea,
we talked about a
native desk at the FCC.
And after it was vetted
by tribal leaders,
they basically said,
we don't want a desk.
We want an office staffed
with economists, and analysts,
and lawyers, and
engineers to do this work.
We also submitted
recommendations
that were included in the
National Broadband Plan.
But having to work with 567
native nations in this country,
it's going to take a lot.
A lot more work.
We've just barely
taken the first steps.
Last year, we included in
the Stafford Act of FEMA
the inclusion of
broadcast facilities
for emergency recognition.
And technology has
changed the landscape,
broadband in particular.
But across Indian
country, back in 2004,
broadband penetration
was at 10%,
which meant that 90% of
Indian country was dark.
Now we've worked really
hard to close that gap.
And I think we've inched
up, but we don't really
have any hard data
to prove that.
The FCC said perhaps
we're around 25%
penetration at this point.
And so it's a reminder of
the long road ahead of us,
but we have a lot to
celebrate as well.
On April 20, we celebrated
Hiller River Broadcast
Corporation, the first
commercial low-power digital
television station serving
a tribal community.
And that was in Arizona.
On April 21st and 22nd,
we celebrated the National
Broadcast Summit, bringing
together about 70 broadcasters
from Indian country,
to share our stories
around emergency preparedness
communications, which
followed on the heels
of a one week training
on the FEMA ground
in Anniston, Alabama.
And what I basically learned
is that communications
is a fundamental human right.
And that we have to work
to make sure that we
continue to have media access,
control, and ownership.
We may be the fastest growing
network in the country,
but we still have
a long ways to go.
And I'm so happy to be here.
I want to thank Dean Elizabeth
Cohen, Danielle Carpenter,
and Shelly Lowe,
and the organizers
of this fantastic conference.
I've learned a lot.
I hope to take it back
with me to my community.
And I look forward to a
long term partnership.
We need some academics in
native public media circle.
We can use your help to
move this movement forward.
Someone once said, it's not
about talking to the choir,
it's about talking to
those individuals that
don't necessarily
disagree with you,
but who may in some
instances, wholeheartedly,
agree with your position.
But if you can move
them in your direction,
then that's the work
ahead of us. [NON-ENGLISH]
[CLAPPING]
-Thank you so much.
You are amazing, panel.
And we have brought
the microphone
to the center of
the room, if anyone
has questions for the panel.
If you don't, I have
a whole list, as well.
-Hi.
Thank you so much for
your presentations.
It's very inspiring
to be here today.
I have a quick question
about the exoticism
that people of color,
or marginalized people,
still experience.
I think a lot of
people in this room
can attest to the experience
of when someone meets you
and they ask, what are you?
Where are you from?
And it's hard.
We have such
complex genealogies.
There's no fixed geography.
We can trace our roots all over.
So I just want to know
professionally, artistically,
personally, how do you
confront and continue
to deconstruct
the exoticism that
is still placed
on people of color
in the arts and entertainment?
And if so, if you
feel like it's still
kind of an uphill battle
for your work and when
you're about to
attempt a new project?
-Sure.
Go ahead.
-I have that story, too.
It got so when I left and
was in Philadelphia, where
I went to university, I started
just asking people to guess,
for that what are you.
It got to this point where
the sort of quip answer,
like I'm a human being.
But then people
never would guess.
They would guess
everything else.
And then when they did find
out, their eyes lit up,
and it was, for me, one of
the first times of realizing
just how amazing we
are, our cultures are,
and how people want to know.
And so I always try to approach
things from being an ambassador
or being a teacher.
But at the same time,
I think that it's
that other that we are
discussing that I think
causes this separation,
or this feeling
that you are not a human being.
That there's a way to kind
of objectify you as a person.
And so, it's really
just a matter
of helping people to see the
complexities of us, of who
we are.
And that first and foremost,
we're human beings.
-Yeah.
So yeah, I've gotten
the same question.
And especially, because I'm
short haired, and whatever,
so I'm not obviously
native to a lot of folks.
And I got to a
point, same thing,
I went totally the
opposite direction, though.
She's talking about,
I'm a human being.
And I think that I've
used up my swears, too,
so I'm not going
to say it, but I
said I usually say like I'm
f-ing awesome, what are you?
Or whatever.
I'm just too damn good looking.
So like it opens a dialogue.
I combat things with humor
as much as I can the way.
I think when you
make somebody laugh,
it builds a little bridge.
And you're like, all right,
well, let's talk as people now.
I can't, obviously, I can't--
none of us can speak for all
POCM, talking about much
of a battle is left.
And it's forever, man.
And we're always
going to be struggling
to understand each other.
But the best thing is, I think
just to be secure in yourself,
and hope that the
other person is, too
and you guys can
have a dialogue, so.
-Perfectly done.
-Thank you, very much.
-Hello.
Kelly Dennis.
I'm an attorney.
I'm a tribal member of the
Shinnecock nation, also
[INAUDIBLE] Nipmuc, from here.
I was sent to Catholic
school for most
of my-- up until eighth grade.
And every year, they'd have
like these crazy plays.
And we always play something.
And it'd be something the
nuns would put together.
And there would be
this one time where
my mother, she would always
love to-- she's an artist,
so she would love to
do the backgrounds.
And she got so
excited this one year
when we were going to
have, a portion of it
would be to have the Native
Americans, I don't even know,
I was so young.
I must have been like
seven or eight years old.
Anyway, I remember having
like these like glow
in the dark like sprinkle things
that you like twirl around.
And there would be like
tipis and things like that.
And then I look back on it,
and I'm like what in the world
did we do?
And then, again,
it was in a way,
it was conflicting,
because I still
kind of felt a weird pride
in it, because at least they
were acknowledging
that there were natives
in this Catholic school, even
though they were portraying us
so wrongly and with the
tipi and these weird glow
in the dark things.
And then I remember that she,
a few years down the line,
I think she wised
up and they tried
to put on a play of Peter Pan.
And then, she was
like, wait a minute,
now they're just
going to be equating
the kids from the reservation as
basically the mermaids in Peter
Pan.
And they're so fantastical.
And I was just
wondering, I think
that maybe one of the
latest things that I think
I've heard of was if
they do do Peter Pan,
kind of like the
Disney thing or not,
who would portray Tiger Lily?
Is it appropriate that they
cast a Native American woman
in that?
And I was just wondering
your thoughts on that.
-Thank you.
-So I think we can even
take it a little broader
and think about
that role of casting
of native peoples in
very stereotypical roles,
and what your thoughts
are about that.
Should we be embracing
that or should we
be moving away from it?
-If you think of that
Night at the Museum
or-- I mean I think that because
these are there-- and just
my own experience, I do know
that I would never understand
really, honestly when
people would meet me
and would burst into tears
until I met Buffy Sainte-Marie.
She had the Creative
Board Teaching Project
and she asked if I
would be a part of it.
And I went.
And they screened some things
from Sesame Street beforehand.
And when I met her,
I burst into tears
because I realized
she was the only image
of a Native American
woman, positive image,
that I ever saw growing up.
And I kind of went, oh, OK.
I understand this
now a little more.
I think that we get so
starving, and starved,
for just anyone up there so
that you can look up, look out,
into this screen of the world
and feel like that's me,
or that's some reflection of
my experience, and who I am.
And you know so it's
such a difficult world
to be a part of as far as
on this side of the camera.
I mean, I was lucky.
I was able to make a living
at doing what I did-- do.
But at the same
time, you're handed
what I explained in your hand.
So I would never-- I
would always feel positive
about that native woman who
would take that role on, yet
at the same time I would work
diligently to create more three
dimensional human women
characters, and men, too.
All of us, we just
don't get that chance,
so I would never feel
negatively toward that.
-I have a slightly
different perspective.
I think in order to
change the narrative.
And if we're serious about the
roles that are stereotypical,
or those that are
demeaning, or unflavorful
to Native Americans, we
have to draw the line.
Otherwise, we're complicit.
One of the reasons why
Native Public Media sought
to build facilities
across Indian country
was to provide a channel where
we could tell our own stories.
And so, I've seen actors
stand up, walk off,
movie sets because
they felt very strongly
that the depictions
of Native Americans
was not favorable
to Indian country.
And I think, just my
personal views on the matter,
to change the course
of history, you
have to break the tie somewhere.
-No way.
Tiger Lily would have to be
completely ripped apart, taken
down, deconstructed.
A part one of the stereotypes
is the Indian maiden.
And the Indian maiden,
one of her main roles
is to, again, with the
cultivating the wilderness,
conquering the wilderness,
one of her main roles
is to be accessible
to the white guy.
She's never accessible
to her own people.
And so a lot of native women
roles, they do the same thing.
They're don't have a
romantic involvement at all
with any of the characters.
I'm not saying that they need to
have only romantic involvement.
But in that kind of narrative,
it only exists for that
and I think unless she's like
sitting there, sword in hand,
and her only thing is to fight
side-by-side with Peter Pan
and conquer the
hell out of things
and then go back to her people.
That would be a better story,
but outside of that no, no.
Sorry.
-Hi.
My name is Sierra.
I'm a second year student
at Brown University.
And one of my questions that
I was thinking about-- oh,
first of all, thank you all for
speaking, it was really great.
The question I had is
kind of piggybacking off
of the previous question.
And this is coming also
from me being an artist
and having to think very
deeply about this, so.
Do you think the native
art, native people in media,
do you think their
work is inherently
political, or radical?
And also, how do
you deal with that
with like looking at
your own positionalities
and where you come from?
And how do you sort of grapple
with being complicit or being
or engaging in activism?
-Hell, yeah.
Yeah.
-That's my student.
-Again, man, you're
supposed to be dead.
Everything you do
as a native person
is either ironic,
or revolutionary,
because nobody expects
you to even be there.
So hell, yeah.
Yeah You're doing something
big, just by existing, just
by going out and doing work.
So.
-I think even just
living in our villages
up in Alaska, where we've
lived our subsistence hunting
and fishing lifestyles
since the beginning of time.
And the fact that
that is something
that we've had to
continue to battle
and continue to work
against pipelines,
and do what we can for
environmental justice,
or social justice,
economic justice.
All these aspects
are just us being us.
And it's a strange thing
to think that, oh, well,
you don't understand.
If you take away our
subsistence hunting and fishing,
and it's $12 a gallon
for milk, that village
is going to have to dismantle.
They're going to leave their
lands and not live that way.
And out of that dismantling,
a genocide has occurred.
So just the fact of wanting to
maintain the traditions in life
that we live and exist in is
in itself its own, as you said,
it's a protest, or it's
irony or politicism
just by being who you are.
-[NON-ENGLISH] Hello, welcome.
My name is Leah.
I'm from the Narragansett
nation of Rhode Island,
just further south of here.
Welcome to the East Coast.
And being an East Coast person,
the question I have for you
as media professionals
is every year,
Thanksgiving time, we deal
with a Thanksgiving story.
My partner being Wampanoag,
me being an East Coast person.
That is our time where
productions come out
such as Saints and Strangers.
And quite a few
people in the room
are familiar with the disaster
of which that film was,
in which native people,
unfortunately, I
believe they were
misled into this film
and portraying Wampanoag people
and people of the East Coast
in the slate that was
not accurate whatsoever.
And I was wondering how
you feel about the ethics
of native people, or what the
ethics are of native people
portraying other native
people from which they are not
familiar with?
And I know Irene has done
some great work in portraying
many different people.
And what are those ethics
that you follow as an actor?
And what would you suggest
for other people who are
going into that acting world?
-I've been on many projects
where, literally, it was just
assumed that I speak that
particular language, or subset
of songs, or know how to wear
a certain piece of regalia,
clothing.
And it's been a long while
from the very first film
that I worked on, when realizing
like I am not just an actor,
I am an ambassador
and a teacher,
and I have a whole lot of
other things on my shoulders
than just going out and
portraying this woman that I
did all my history research on.
And I did all the things that
I would do from a point of view
approaching any character.
But it's gotten
better in the realms
of where there have been more
extensive casting directors who
do more extensive
work in finding people
from those traditions,
those tribes.
But the thing that
I hold on to is
that I come from a
cultural perspective
of belonging to a tribe.
Strangely enough, I've never
spoken my own language, yet.
But so I have those abilities
to know what to ask for,
and what to push
for, and who to ask,
and who should be presented.
And literally, on one
film, out of speaking
with the producers
and the directors,
they went and hired someone
to represent the tribe
that we were representing to
be there as a cultural advisor.
And so that has that happens
more and more often, but still
not enough.
And to find that kind
of realm between someone
who has the financial power
to make this million dollar
film be sold in some
form of distribution,
yet at the same time
represents native people.
Yet, you hear people say,
oh, well we looked for people
but we couldn't find
them, because there's
nobody out there.
And you go, what?
So it's been a long struggle.
It is a long struggle.
It will continue to be that way.
We just have to create
more of a group of people
from every community,
if that's the case, who
are both behind the camera,
in front of the camera.
That is something that our
production company is working
to do, and others are working
toward doing, is to create
a workforce of us
in our communities
that understand and
know this business.
-[NON-ENGLISH]
-So will you all please
join me in thanking
our esteemed panelists?
-That Was just an amazing panel.
Dr. Keene, everybody, thank
you, so much for everything
you've done today.
And just one more round
of applause for the panel.
Thank you.
[CLAPPING]
Go ahead, you guys can go.
-Oh, any body that knows
April, she says hi.
-All right.
I'm going to say a few
concluding remarks here.
But I don't want to get
in the way of the picture,
so, make sure that's kosher.
What a day.
Rob Porter told me that he would
win a bet if he said the term
goat rodeo in his talk.
Rob, if I say it, do
you still win that bet?
-No.
-OK.
Do you want to say it now?
Because I didn't
hear you say it.
-No.
-OK.
He's willing to lose that bet.
I'm absolving myself
of all responsibility.
-I won it.
-Oh, OK.
You won.
All right, so great.
This is, in my 15
years at Harvard,
perhaps the most
meaningful, single day
that I've seen on this campus.
It was just wonderful.
[CLAPPING]
Thank you, every body here.
Just a couple
reflections to conclude.
The diversity, we
kept on coming back
to stories and storytelling,
and the diversity of stories
that we've heard in, the
forms in which they were told.
Just this last panel, stories
being told through data.
Adrienne's data.
Irene Bedard's data,
quantitative visual data.
Richard Guest's data on how
often people won or lost
in front of the Supreme Court.
Stories told with statistics,
a tool, of native politics.
Stories through
visual representation.
Matika Wilbur, obviously, but
also Kristiana Kahakauwila's
inversion or
resplicing, if you will,
of the map of the Pacific,
of Oceana, I'm sorry.
Stories told through
political battle tales
won and lost, sometimes
funny, sometimes not funny.
Stories through violence retold,
whether domestic violence,
sexual violence, symbolic
violence, military violence.
Stories through song, not just
Frank Wong's beautiful hip hop,
but also Jonathan
Perry this morning.
Thank you, again.
Story through comedy.
Story through tragedy.
As I listened to
the third panel,
with Kristiana Kahakauwila
repieced together the Pacific,
making whole again Oceana,
and as I wiped away two tears,
I think there were
two, listening
to Frank Wong and
his song, and as I
listen to Irene Bedard
talk about being
whole on our feet, where the
left wing and the right wing
are part of the same animal.
As I listened to
these storytellers,
I realize that together,
everybody here today, we
had, even if partially, been
made whole today ourselves.
Maybe some of us had
even been healed.
And for that I want to
thank the person who really
is most responsible for
putting this all together,
because she signed on to the
idea about a year and a half
ago, now.
A lot of planning goes
into this conference.
And that's Dean Liz Cohen,
our fearless leader.
And as of last
night, with the gift
from Matika Wilbur, Chief Cohen.
And I say that because
that was because that
was Matika's thing.
Becky Wasserman, director of
academic ventures at Radcliffe.
Paul Beran, this
amazing Radcliffe staff,
that runs these
conferences like a machine
that you can set your watch to.
Right?
HUNAP and the amazing work
that you do, unbelievable work.
Not to be forgotten,
Maggie McKinley who
has just done such amazing
planning work, and again
my colleague.
So today I hope we heard
native voices, native politics,
native peoples
amplified at Harvard.
And that by amplifying native
voices, Harvard and Radcliffe,
again, to use the metaphor,
have been made more whole,
if just for a day.
And as we move
forward, I'm reminded
of the daily work that
HUNAP, Shelly, and Dennis,
and Jason, and Sam, and
others, and their students.
The daily work that they
do in institutionalizing
that native voice at Harvard.
And I'm reminded that,
in order, for Harvard
to be made whole in the future,
today's conversation needs
to happen again, and
again, and again.
In order for Harvard
to be made whole,
the kinds of people you saw
today need to on our faculty.
[CLAPPING]
And in order for Harvard
to be made whole again,
maybe some of the same
people you saw here today
need to be on our faculty,
Adrienne Keene, Maggie
McKinley, Kristiana
Kahakauwila, Alyssa Mt.
Pleasant, Rob Porter, or
they, or others, and I
apologize for anybody I
left out-- Matika, you, too,
come teach here-- they
need to be on our faculty.
And that's not all.
Harvard needs to recognize
the living reality
of Native American lives,
Native American languages,
Native American peoples.
So today, native peoples did
native politics at Harvard.
Native peoples performed
native politics.
And thank you to my native
sisters and brothers
for having done it.
It was a beautiful.
Thank you.
[CLAPPING]
-Well, it's been an amazing day.
And I don't think
I need to say it,
Dan, you said it so
beautifully, as has everyone.
I just want to thank the
organizers for this, Dan,
and Shelly, and Maggie,
Becky, Paul, the staff.
This was a day when everybody
helped at the Radcliffe
Institute, as they do when
we have events like this,
and I want to thank
everybody for doing that.
Our panelists were just,
one better than the other,
more moving than the
other, we are so grateful.
People came from very
far away to be here.
And I also want to help to thank
the audience because I think
you made this event as special
as it was by being so engaged,
asking really honest questions,
putting yourselves out there,
being part of the story.
So now it's time to celebrate.
We're just a door away
from food and drink.
And it will be
wonderful to be together
in a more informal setting.
But please, join me once
again to thank everybody
for making today possible.
[MUSIC PLAYING]